Why should we believe that Muhammad was
a true prophet?
Well, in the Quran, Allah claims that
there are prophecies about Muhammad in
the Torah.
Sura 7:157
of the Quran refers to those who follow
the Apostle Prophet, the Ummi. Ummi is
usually translated as unlettered or
illiterate,
whom they find written down with them in
the Taurat, the Torah, and the Injil,
the Gospel.
Notice that the Quran appeals to the
Torah and the Gospel to support belief
in Muhammad, which would be strange if
the Quran taught that the Torah and the
Gospel were corrupted. Fortunately, the
Quran affirms the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the Torah
and the Gospel. Indeed, according to the
Quran itself, the Quran should only be
treated as divine revelation if it lines
up with the Torah and the Gospel, as we
read in Sura 10:94,
where Allah says to Muhammad,
"But if you are in doubt as to what we
have revealed to you, ask those who read
the book before you." Those who read the
book before him are Jews and Christians,
the people of the book.
Here again, it would be strange for the
Quran to proclaim the Torah and the
Gospel as the authority over whether the
Quran is revelation from God if the
Quran is claiming that the Torah and the
Gospel were corrupted. And again,
fortunately, the Quran never says that
the Torah and the Gospel were corrupted.
That's a Muslim myth.
So, if the Torah and the Gospel don't
line up with the Quran, or if the Torah
and the Gospel don't contain prophecies
about Muhammad, we should reject
Muhammad and the Quran.
Muslims have had around 14 centuries to
find any prophecies about Muhammad in
the Torah, and their favorite example of
a so-called prophecy of Muhammad in the
Torah comes from Deuteronomy 18, where
Moses predicts the rise of another
prophet after him.
This argument is popular in our time
thanks to Muslim speakers like Zakir
Naik.
Book of Deuteronomy, chapter number 18,
verse number 18, Almighty God says, "I
shall raise them up a prophet from among
my brethren like unto thee, and I shall
put my words into his mouth, and he
shall speak all that I command him."
It's still being used by the new
generation of powerful Dawah minds such
as Lily J.
Hi Lily J. Yes, there are several verses
in the Bible that many scholars and
Muslims believe refer to Prophet
Muhammad. One of the most famous
references is in the book of
Deuteronomy, chapter 18, verse 18, where
God promises to send another prophet
like Moses. The Hilali-Khan translation
of the Quran is the version usually
given to Hajj pilgrims, and the
translators even add a reference to
Deuteronomy 18 in their translation of
Sura 7, verse 157, which reads,
"Those who follow the messenger, the
prophet who can neither read nor write,
i.e. Muhammad, whom they find written
with them in the Taurat Torah,
Deuteronomy 18:15,
and the Injil Gospel, John 14:16."
So, the translators put the reference to
the Bible in their translation of the
Quran.
Sounds like they really think
Deuteronomy 18 contains a clear and
powerful prophecy about Muhammad.
Let's read verses 15 through 19 of
Deuteronomy 18, and then I'll tell you
what the Muslim argument is. Moses says
to the children of Israel,
"The Lord your God will up for you a
prophet like me from among you, from
your brothers. It is to him you shall
listen, just as you desired of the Lord
your God at Horeb on the day of the
assembly, when you said, "Let me not
hear again the voice of the Lord my God
or see this great fire anymore, lest I
die."
And the Lord said to me, "They are right
in what they have spoken. I will raise
up for them a prophet like you from
among their brothers, and I will put my
words in his mouth, and he shall speak
to them all that I command him. And
whoever will not listen to my words that
he shall speak in my name, I myself will
require it of him."
Muslims point either to verse 15, as we
saw in the Hilali-Khan translation of
the Quran, or more commonly to verse 18,
because, as we'll soon see, verse 15 has
a glaring problem for the Muslim
argument.
They claim that this prophecy could only
have been fulfilled by Muhammad, who,
like Moses, was a lawgiver, and a
prophet, and a military leader.
Further, this prophet would arise from
the brothers of the Israelites, and who
are the brothers of the Israelites if
not the Ishmaelites, Muhammad's
purported ancestors, because Ishmael was
the brother of Isaac, the father of
Israel.
That's the argument in a nutshell.
Sadly, for our Muslim friends, anyone
who actually reads the book of
Deuteronomy will start to notice some
serious problems with their argument.
First, the passage says that God will
raise up a prophet like Moses
because the Israelites didn't want to
hear directly from God.
God speaking to them directly was too
terrifying, so they wanted to hear God's
words through some sort of mediator.
And this fits the immediate context of
the passage because right before verses
15 to 19, we have verses 9 to 14 where
Moses tells them how they're not going
to receive revelations. He tells them,
"When you come into the land that the
Lord your God is giving you, you shall
not learn to follow the abominable
practices of those nations.
There shall not be found among you
anyone who burns his son or his daughter
as an offering, anyone who practices
divination or tells fortunes or
interprets omens, or a sorcerer or a
charmer or a medium or a necromancer or
one who inquires of the dead. For
whoever does these things is an
abomination to the Lord.
And because of these abominations, the
Lord your God is driving them out before
you.
You shall be blameless before the Lord
your God. For these nations, which you
are about to dispossess, listen to
fortune-tellers and to diviners. But as
for you, the Lord your God has not
allowed you to do this.
So, when they enter the land, the land
of Israel, they aren't allowed to seek
revelations from diviners or
fortune-tellers or omen interpreters or
sorcerers or charmers or mediums or
necromancers and so on.
How are they going to receive
revelations? Next passage. They could
have received revelations directly from
God, but that was too scary. Instead,
God would send them a prophet.
According to the immediate context then,
this is simply telling the Israelites
how they were going to hear from God
once they entered the land of Israel.
God would send them a prophet.
That prophet would eventually die, and
God would send them another prophet.
This passage, again, according to the
immediate context,
is about God sending the Israelites a
series of prophets to speak to them on
his behalf.
Each of these prophets would be like
Moses in that they would speak to the
Israelites on God's behalf so that the
Israelites wouldn't have to hear the
terrifying voice of God.
But, there's a connected passage in
Deuteronomy 34, we'll read it shortly,
which suggested that there would be some
supreme fulfillment of this prophecy,
some special prophet who would be like
Moses in an even greater way.
So, according to the immediate context,
this prophecy is about God sending
prophets to the Israelites, not to the
Arabs. According to the extended
context, there would be a special
prophet who would be a greater
fulfillment of the prophecy.
Just so you don't think I'm making this
up, let's read a note from the ESV Study
Bible.
Deuteronomy, note on 18:15-19.
God promises a line of prophets who will
speak to Israel on his behalf. Compare
Jeremiah 1:7 and 9 pertaining to
Jeremiah's ministry.
Moses speaks of himself as a prophet,
the instrument of communicating God's
word to Israel. Compare Deuteronomy
18:19, Exodus 7:1.
Nations listen, Deuteronomy 18:14, to
magicians, etc. Israel is to listen to
God's prophet, verses 15 and 19, rather
than pagan means of revelation and
guidance.
On the voice of the Lord, see 5:23-28.
A prophet like you.
Now, God speaks of Moses as a prophet
and promises a future prophet like him
for Israel.
In the 1st century AD, Jews expected a
final prophet whom New Testament writers
identified as Jesus. Acts 3:22-24,
7:37, compare John 1:21.
Hence, this passage is about God sending
prophets to the Israelites.
There's nothing here that points to
Muhammad.
Next, I mentioned that there's a glaring
problem for our Muslim friends in
Deuteronomy 18:15. Let's read it one
more time.
The Lord your God will raise up for you,
the children of Israel, a prophet like
me, like Moses, from among you.
From among who?
From among you, the children of Israel.
Was Muhammad an Israelite?
No.
This is why Muslims ignore the from
among you part and focus instead on the
from your brothers part, which is
synonymous with from among you.
And they insist that from your brothers
refers to Ishmaelites without the
slightest bit of evidence for this.
From your brothers in Deuteronomy never
refers to Ishmaelites. When it's used
without qualification, as it is here in
Deuteronomy 18, it always always always
refers to fellow Israelites. And it's
often used to distinguish Israelites
from non-Israelites.
Let's look at some verses just from
Deuteronomy.
Deuteronomy 1:16.
And I charged your judges at that time,
"Hear the cases between your brothers,
and judge righteously between a man and
his brother or the alien who is with
him."
Judge righteously between a man and his
brother or the alien. Brother refers to
a fellow Israelite. Alien refers to a
non-Israelite. There's a distinction.
Deuteronomy 17:15. This is the chapter
right before Deuteronomy 18.
You may indeed set a king over you whom
the Lord your God will choose.
One from among your brothers you shall
set as king over you. You may not put a
foreigner over you who is not your
brother.
One from among your brothers you shall
set as king over you. What does this
mean?
Were they supposed to get an Ishmaelite
as their king?
Were they supposed to get an Arab king?
No. One from among your brothers,
meaning a fellow Israelite. And the
verse makes a distinction between
brothers and foreigners.
Deuteronomy 24:14.
You shall not oppress a hired worker who
is poor and needy, whether he is one of
your brothers or one of the sojourners
who are in your land within your towns.
Once again, there's a distinction
between your brothers, fellow
Israelites, and sojourners,
non-Israelites living among them.
Ishmaelites and other groups can be
brothers in a certain sense because
they're relatives, but when Deuteronomy
uses the phrase from among your brothers
without any qualification, it always
always always refers to fellow
Israelites.
So, when we read that God would raise up
for you a prophet like me from among
you, from your brothers, this doesn't
point to Muhammad as the fulfillment.
It rules out Muhammad as the
fulfillment.
Third, the Muslim argument is based on
the idea that Muhammad is like Moses in
the relevant sense. God says that he
will raise up a prophet like Moses, and
Muslims draw attention to various
similarities between Moses and Muhammad.
But, as we've seen, like Moses in the
context of Deuteronomy 18, simply means
that prophets would speak to the
Israelites on God's behalf so that the
Israelites wouldn't have to hear
directly from God.
But, I mentioned that there's a later
passage in Deuteronomy that suggests
some sort of supreme example of a
prophet like Moses.
The book of Deuteronomy ends with
chapter 34, verses 9 through 12.
And Joshua, the son of Nun, was full of
the spirit of wisdom, for Moses had laid
his hands on him.
So, the people of Israel obeyed him and
did as the Lord had commanded Moses.
And there has not arisen a prophet since
in Israel like Moses,
whom the Lord knew face to face, none
like him for all the signs and the
wonders that the Lord sent him to do in
the land of Egypt, to Pharaoh and to all
his servants, and to all his land, and
for all the mighty power and all the
great deeds of terror that Moses did in
the sight of all Israel.
According to Deuteronomy 34, the
extended context, the phrase like Moses
refers to a prophet who would know God
face to face and perform signs and
wonders in the sight of all Israel.
Muhammad doesn't fit either of these
criteria. Muhammad supposedly received
his revelations from Gabriel, not
directly from God, and according to the
Quran, he couldn't perform miracles like
Moses.
In the Quran, Muhammad was repeatedly
asked about why he couldn't perform
miracles.
And Allah never answers, "What are you
talking about? Muhammad performs
miracles all the time, just like Moses."
On the contrary, the Quran makes excuses
for why Muhammad couldn't perform
miracles. We'll read a few verses. There
are plenty more.
Surah 6, verse 37. And they say, "Why
has not a sign been sent down to him
from his Lord?" Say, "Surely Allah is
able to send down a sign, but most of
them do not know."
Why didn't Allah send Muhammad with a
miraculous sign? Well, Allah was able to
send down a sign, but he decided not to.
Surah 10, verse 20. And they say, "Why
is not a sign sent to him from his
Lord?"
Say, "The unseen is only for Allah.
Therefore, wait. Surely I, too, with you
am of those who wait."
Why didn't Allah send a sign to
Muhammad? The world may never know,
because the unseen is only for Allah.
So, just keep waiting.
Surah 11, verse 12. Then, it may be that
you, Muhammad, will give up part of what
is revealed to you, and your breast will
become straightened by it, because they
say, "Why has not a treasure been sent
down upon him, or an angel come with
him?"
"You are only a warner, and Allah is
custodian over all things."
Here, Allah is worried that Muhammad's
feelings will be hurt, because he wasn't
given any miracles.
Surah 13, verse 7. "And those who
disbelieve say, 'Why has not a sign been
sent down upon him from his Lord?' You
are only a warner, and there is a guide
for every people."
Why didn't Allah send Muhammad with a
sign? Because Muhammad was only a
warner.
Surah 13, verse 27. "And those who
disbelieve say, 'Why is not a sign sent
down upon him by his Lord?'
Say, "Surely Allah makes him who will go
astray and guides to himself those who
turn to him."
Why didn't Allah send Muhammad with a
sign? Because signs are irrelevant.
Allah decides who's going to believe and
who's not going to believe. So, who
needs a sign?
Surah 17, verse 59. "And nothing could
have hindered us that we should send
signs except that the ancients rejected
them. And we gave to Thamud the
she-camel, a manifest sign, but on her
account they did injustice, and we do
not send signs but to make men fear."
Why didn't Allah send any miraculous
signs to show that Muhammad has his
stamp of approval? Because some people
in the past rejected miracles. So, Allah
decided to stop sending them.
Surah 29, verses 50 to 51. "And they
say, 'Why are not signs sent down upon
him from his Lord?'"
Say, "The signs are only with Allah, and
I am only a plain warner."
"Is it not enough for them that we have
revealed to you the book which is
recited to them?"
"Most surely there is mercy in this and
a reminder for a people who believe."
Why didn't Allah send a miracle? Well,
he did, but it's just the Quran.
So, according to the immediate context
of Deuteronomy 18, the passage is saying
that God would send prophets to the
Israelites so that they wouldn't have to
hear directly from God.
According to the extended context in
Deuteronomy 34, the ultimate prophet
like Moses would know God face-to-face
and perform signs and wonders.
Here again, this doesn't point to
Muhammad as the fulfillment, it rules
out Muhammad as the fulfillment.
Finally, while Muslims appeal to
Deuteronomy 18:15-19 as evidence for
their prophet, they really, really need
to read the very next verse, which shows
that Muhammad can't possibly be the
prophet like Moses.
In Deuteronomy 18:20, God declares,
"But the prophet who presumes to speak a
word in my name that I have not
commanded him to speak,
or who speaks in the name of other gods,
that same prophet shall die."
Notice, God gives two criteria for
recognizing a false prophet. One, if a
person delivers a revelation that
doesn't actually come from God, the
person is a false prophet.
Two, if a person speaks in the name of
other gods,
the person is a false prophet.
Interestingly, Muhammad meets both
criteria for a false prophet because he
delivered the infamous Satanic Verses to
his followers.
According to Muslim sources, dozens of
Muslim sources,
Muhammad once delivered a revelation to
his followers telling them that they
could pray to the pagan goddesses Allat,
Al-Uzza, and Manat. Here's one version
of the story in History of al-Tabari,
volume six, page 111.
The messenger of God was sitting in a
large gathering of Quraysh, that's his
tribe, wishing that day that no
revelation would come to him from God
which would cause them to turn away from
him.
Then God revealed, "By the star when it
sets, your comrade does not err,
nor is he deceived." That's verses one
and two of Sura 53.
And the messenger of God recited it
until he came to, "Have you thought upon
Allat and Al-Uzza and Manat, the third,
the other?" That's verses 19 and 20 of
Sura 53.
When Satan cast on his tongue two
phrases,
"These are the high-flying cranes.
Verily, their intercession is to be
desired.
He uttered them and went on to complete
the sura.
When he prostrated himself at the end of
the sura, the whole company prostrated
themselves with him.
Allat, Al-Uzza, and Manat were called
the high-flying cranes because they were
like birds who could carry our prayers
up to Allah.
Shortly after Muhammad delivered these
verses which promoted polytheism,
Gabriel confronted Muhammad about his
sin, and Muhammad confessed,
"I have fabricated things against God
and have imputed to him words which he
has not spoken."
Since Muhammad delivered a revelation
that didn't come from God, he meets the
first criterion of a false prophet in
Deuteronomy 18:20. And since the verses
he delivered promote prayers to pagan
goddesses, he meets the second criterion
as well.
Hence, the passage that Muslims point to
as their primary prophecy about Muhammad
in the Torah actually shows that
Muhammad can't be a prophet at all.
Notice
what would have happened to Muhammad if
he had delivered the satanic verses
during the time of Moses. Deuteronomy
18:20 says,
"But the prophet who presumes to speak a
word in my name that I have not
commanded him to speak or who speaks in
the name of other gods, that same
prophet shall die."
If Muhammad had delivered the satanic
verses during the time of Moses, Moses
would have ordered the Israelites to
execute him as a false prophet.
Putting all of this together,
>> [snorts]
>> Muslims go to Deuteronomy 18 as their
best case for a prophecy about Muhammad
in the Torah.
But when we read the passage, we find
that it's about God sending prophets to
the Israelites so that they wouldn't
have to hear his voice directly.
That doesn't fit Muhammad.
We find that these prophets would be
Israelites, not Ishmaelites.
That rules out Muhammad.
We find that the ultimate fulfillment
from the extended context would be
someone who knows God face-to-face and
who performs signs and wonders.
That rules out Muhammad.
And we find that since Muhammad
delivered the satanic verses to his
followers, he can't possibly be a
prophet according to Deuteronomy 18.
If this is the best passage that Muslim
apologists have been able to come up
with after 14 centuries of searching
through the Torah,
we can only wonder how long it will take
them to realize that according to the
Bible, Muhammad was a false prophet.
If you like an even more detailed
response to Muslim arguments about
Muhammad in Deuteronomy 18, be sure to
watch Inspiring Philosophy's video about
whether Muhammad is the prophet like
Moses. The link is in the description.
You got to try me now. You got to try me
now.
>> [music]
>> Yeah.